c'est une première le maire écologiste
de grande synthe a porté plainte contre
l'état pour inaction climatique
une démarche pour ne pas voir
disparaître la nature dans sa ville car
depuis 2001 année de sa première
élection
l'élu s'est lancé un défi le retour de
la biodiversité à grande synthe seconde
partie - là nous cet environnement soit
le lieu c'est pour ça qu'on veut le
développer en challenge audacieux pour
cette ville du nord de la france
encerclée depuis les années 60 par la
sidérurgie et la pétrochimie
soit une quinzaine de sites industriels
classés seveso les dunes ont disparu le
paysage est maintenant marqué par la
fumée la ligne des hauts fourneaux
d'usinor les citernes à pétrole les
parois d'acier et de béton des unités
qui viennent s'implanter sur ce littoral
autrefois calme et plats et pour loger
les ouvriers des usines les hlm poussait
aussi comme des champignons à grande
synthe les immeubles alignés ou 6500
famille lift au rythme des trois-huit
d'usinor les familles s'efforce de ne
faire qu'un bref passage dans cette
grande et froide cité ou au départ tout
a été conçu pour loger mais pas pour
vivre à cette époque c'est le père de
damien carême qui est le maire de la
ville sa volonté était déjà là même que
son fils une révolution verte à
grande-synthe
la première des choses que j'ai faites
moi
on est en mer c'est d'acheter des
terrains pour pouvoir planter
1972 rené carême c'est très hanter ce
qui deviendra le puythouck le poumon
vert de la ville bordée par un lac de 30
hectares est aujourd'hui la nature a
bien repris ses droits dans la ville
industrielle
la municipalité a banni les pesticides
dans ces espaces verts
optez pour des parkings non goudronnée
introduit l'écopâturage et même
construit des logements sociaux économes
en énergie résultat en 2010 grande
synthe devient capitale française de la
biodiversité
voilà c'est sont des choix qui ont été
faits politiques à une certaine époque à
40 ans et qui se sont continus et depuis
c'est une image autre et un regard autre
que maintenant les personnes extérieures
à la ville porte sur 25
une fierté partagée aussi par les
habitants de grande synthe en 2012
damien carême signal sharp
internationale pour la biodiversité
grande synthe est l'une des 20 villes du
monde à l'avoir adopté au côté de
johannesburg sao paulo barcelone
[Musique]